[Musik]
mit ihrem markenzeichen dem pagenkopf
und dunkler sonnenbrille beherrscht
einer linzer das 300 milliarden dollar
schwere amerikanische mode
info anna ist der einflussreichste
mensch in der modewelt
als chefredakteurin der vogue wurde sie
selbst für einer berühmtheit mit dem ruf
einer guten fee mantel winters
anerkennung ist wichtig für alles was
ich tue und eines feuerspuckenden
drachen für andere ich habe gehört wie
eiskönigin oder nuklearer winter aber um
ergebnisse zu erzielen musste
anspruchsvoll sein ist sie ein wahrer
sanfter mensch nein warum sollte sie
dass sein
einfluss ist über die saiten des
hochglanzmagazins hinausgewachsen sie
ist einen schrittmacher
sie ist die frau die mode international
und zum großen geschäft gemacht hat
[Musik]
ich weiß nichts über mode und ich lese
die burg nicht regelmäßig aber ich weiß
eine menge über sie anna winter stellte
sich ohne umschweife ihren
sagenumwobenen ruf einem ihrer seltenen
fernsehauftritte
ich habe diese woche in der new york
times gelesen dass ich eine eiskönigin
bin ich bin der sonnenkönig ich bin ein
alien aus dem district 9 und eine domina
also ich schätze das macht mich zu einer
lauwarmen adeligen aus dem all mit einer
peitsche
was denken sie guter auftritt
[Applaus]
ihr auftritt ist der der chefredakteuren
der politik 22 jahre lang hat die
mächtige und einschüchternde
bienenkönigin frauen gesagt was und wen
sie zu tragen haben lange röcke oder
kurze royal oder marineblau oder das
grau das neue schwarz ist ich bete mode
an ich bete an was sie über frauen sagt
die vogue ist anerkannt wie kein anderes
magazin und das ist unglaublich
befriedigend
anna ist revolutionär sie hat die ganze
mode industrie revolutioniert
anna ist jemand der mit konkurrenzdenken
umgeht in einer weise wie das jeder
machen sollte sie wird nicht wütend sie
wird
mit ihrem irish winter manager medien
profil mit viel sorgfalt und lehnte es
ab an unserem programm teilzunehmen
[Musik]
mit einer winter war schon als junge
frau ehrgeizig 1949 in london geboren
verließ sie in den 60er jahren die
schule und war fasziniert von der
londoner gesellschaft und kultur ziehen
ihre mutter eleonore amerikanerin und
ihr britischer vater charles war der
abgebrühte chefredakteur der londoner
zeitung evening standard laurie
scheckter begann ihre karriere als anna
winters assistentin
sie wuchs mit einem journalisten auf
einem zeitungsmann beherrschte ein
gewisser standard eine strenge die sich
sicherlich auf sie ausgewirkt hat und so
geht sie nun noch alles an
als sie 20 waren bekam winter ihren gut
bekleideten fuß in die tür beim gerade
gegründeten britischen magazin hafen
queen sie war außerordentlich eifrig sie
holte sich die besten fotografen um die
leiter hoch zu klettern aber nach fünf
jahren bei rapid wien wurde sie bei der
wahl eines neuen chefredakteurs
engagiert sie verließ das magazin und
england und macht er sich 1975 auf dem
weg zur seventh avenue in new york
sitzt an der spitze ihres eigenen
modeunternehmens und kennt winter seit
über 30 jahren
sie war nicht anna wintour die
hohepriesterin der vogue sie war meine
freundin und wir waren zwei mädchen die
versuchten etwas in der modeindustrie in
gang zu bringen
anna war definitiv darauf aus in
zeitschriften geschäft zu gehen und vor
allem zur vogue
aber die vogue mussten noch warten ihren
ersten job in new york hatte winter bei
harper's bazaar und wurde gefeuert weil
sie wie sie in einem zeitungsinterview
sagt zu europäisch war
nach ein paar monaten ohne arbeit nahm
sie ein jobangebot vom herausgeber des
penthouse magazins boccioni an als
moderedakteurin bei viva einem
erotikmagazin für frauen ihre models
gewannen an anerkennung ein paar jahre
später bekam sie ihren ersten großen job
mode redakteurin beim new york
sie war ein totales rätsel ein
faszinierendes rätsel sie trug diese
dunkle sonnenbrille so ziemlich die
ganze zeit es hieß schwimmen oder sinken
sie sagte was sie wollte aber nicht wie
du es machen so ist ich habe in zwei
wochen vier kilo verloren weil das die
ganze zeit zu gehen
winter erarbeitete sich eine stilvolle
layout und eine unerbittliche
arbeitsmoral
[Musik]
sie hatte eine sehr festgelegte
tagesordnung sie hatte den mut und den
schneid und intelligenz und die energie
um all das zu tun
es hat nicht lange gedauert bis die
manager bei continuous und alexander
lieberman auf sie aufmerksam
war verlagsleiter bei der vogue und
kennt winter seit 30 jahren
dieser anfangszeit fühlte sich fast an
die in einem jungen hollywood studio und
herr newhouse und alex hatten einfach
diesen großartigen sinn nicht nur dafür
wie man ein magazin hochzieht sondern
auch für die persönlichkeiten wie diese
magazine leiten sollten die organisation
hat leute mit einer vision und mit
entschlossenheit und tatkraft wirklich
mit offenen armen begrüßt niemand hatte
mehr tatkraft als anna winter sie wurde
mit einem job bei der wo belohnt denn
nur für sie geschaffen würde es war
nicht der job den sie sich gewünscht
hatte den hatte bereits die langjährige
chefredakteurin
es gab offensichtlich widerstand aber
wenn anna hereinkommt ist sie kein
mauerblümchen und macht ihren standpunkt
klar und deshalb wurde sie dort hin
unter standpunkt kam bei mir aber nicht
in ihrer autobiografie bezeichnete sie
die neue kreativdirektorin als kalte und
misstrauische person die immer gegen sie
arbeitete
untergraben sie schrieb dass sie das
gefühl habe dass winter darauf
vorbereitet wurde ihren job zu
übernehmen
ich glaube es gab welche die sich
bedroht fühlten sie kannten sie nicht
sie wussten nicht genau warum sie hier
war und sie würden nicht jeden neuen
einfach so willkommen heißen
ganz zu schweigen von jemandem wie anna
die eine ziemlich gute figur machte und
definitiv die aufmerksamkeit der großen
entscheidungsträger von kontinent auf
sich zog
[Musik]
nach einem dreijährigen machtkampf legte
kontinent einen ozean zwischen sehen sie
boten windeln eine beförderung zu
chefredakteurin der britischen vogue an
ein weiterer schritt auf der
karriereleiter der mit hohem
persönlichen kosten verbunden war frisch
und horst winter zog mit ihrem baby nach
london während ihr mann in new york
1986 kam sie nach london und begann
sofort das erscheinungsbild der
britischen vogue zu verändern
wales ja in gewisser weise machte sie so
bodenständiger für leute die auf der
suche nach dingen waren die sie auch
kaufen könnten und sie machte das
magazin nutzerfreundlicher den lesern
malz diese abwechslung gefallen haben
aber ihre mitarbeiter waren nicht sehr
begeistert sie gaben ihr einen
spitznamen der blieb nuklearer winter
es ist ein bisschen dass greta garbo
ding wenn man nicht viel sagt und die
leute nicht einbindet aber das führt
dazu dass sich der rest der welt selbst
überlegt was wohl sache ist
ist sie warm und sanft nein warum sollte
sie
ist sie jemand dessen meinung man gerne
hätte absolut nach 18 monaten holte
condé nast den aufstrebenden star zurück
nach new york um ihr einrichtungs
magazin haus im garten zu überholen
winter änderte den titel in age sie
kaufte bilder von leeren räumen gegen
üppige fotostrecken
manche leser empörten sich und die
zeitschrift c't war gezwungen abos
zurück zu erstatten wollen terry jones
damals dienstälteste mode redakteurin
beim wall street journal und autorin des
buches das ende der mode
deshalb nenne ich ein revolutionär weil
sie in so ein etabliertes magazin
einsteigt uns so etwas radikales tut die
gefahr dass man scheitert ist so hoch
waren etwas mutiges macht
andere karrieren wären von solchen
misserfolgen beendet wurden doch nicht
die anna winter kontinent hatte noch
andere pläne mit ihren es war das am
schlechtesten gehütete geheimnis es gab
gerüchte dass wintour chefredakteurin
der amerikanischen vogue werden und die
veteranen grace mirabelle ersetzen würde
nun die heiße story ist dass das wohl
auch passieren wird nach 17 jahren
die 38 jährige anna winter bekam den job
ging sie immer wollte ihre vision von
ihrem ersten cover an klar sie
kombinierte einen 10.000 dollar oberteil
mit einer 40 dollar jeans
das war etwas neues revolutionäres das
war eine neue herausgeberin sie war
briten sie was die voll sie war jung und
sie hatte einen standpunkt wir wussten
dass das eine neue ära sein würde in
einem interview im dezember 88 erklärte
winter was es heißt chefredakteurin der
vogue zu sein ich denke das wichtigste
in diesem job ist den richtigen instinkt
und das richtige bauchgefühl zu haben um
ein magazin zu produzieren das aus dem
moment heraus geboren wird das einfach
einfängt was sie jetzt gerade passiert
man muss mitten drin sein
[Musik]
mirabel us traditionelle titel bilder
wurden durch winters frischen neuen look
ersetzt
sie scheute keine kosten für aufwändige
shootings mit den besten fotografen
[Musik]
er wusste genau wie sie unserem wunsch
nach flucht und schönheit und echter
mode verbindet und mit dem bedürfnis
nach den dingen die uns frauen wichtig
sind dinge die zu unserem lebensstil
passen wer wir sind und wo wir herkommen
wieder einmal erkannte winter die
anziehungskraft von promis und ersetzte
supermodels durch superstar dem cover
filmemacher jay cutler
winter hat sehr früh erkannt dass die
macht der prominenten globale industrie
und die mode zusammenkamen
wir hatten die mega marken gucci prada
airways berufstätige frauen übernahmen
führungspositionen also brauchten sich
bauer kleidung für die arbeit
sie verstand den glamour der top mode
den wunsch die menschen träumen nach
etwas streben zu lassen sie zu
inspirieren
aber sie verstand auch wie sich die mode
als geschäft verändert hat
[Musik]
winters steigen das ansehen führte zu
steigenden werbeeinnahmen
madonna war herausgeber der
modezeitschrift
das werbegeschäft kann sehr launisch
sein sie müssen im laufe der zeit
loyalität aufbauen sie müssen den
werbetreibenden einen echten mehrwert
und gründe bieten um konsequent in ihren
publikationen zu bleiben weil es eine
der wettbewerbsfähigsten branche der
welt ist
innerhalb von zehn jahren stiegen die
werbeeinnahmen von knapp über 87
millionen dollar auf fast 150 millionen
dollar der erfolg der bus brachte winter
wachsenden einfluss
ihre auftritte in den ersten reihen der
modeschauen mit ihrer dunklen
sonnenbrille erhielten eine ganz neue
bedeutung
jeder eisige gesichtsausdruck wurde nach
hinweisen durchsucht
[Musik]
wurde ein wichtiger show gast wenn sie
da war war es wie eine bestätigung dass
deine show cool ist eine große sache
unter winter verwandelte sich die rose
vom magazin zur marke
der erfolg rückte auch sie in den
öffentlichen fokus
1999 berichtete die boulevard zeitungen
über ihre scheidung und ihre beziehung
zum texanischen telekom millionär shelby
kobe bryant
die leute traten und spekulierten rede
ihrer bewegungen aber sie hat es im
grunde genommen ignoriert und ich glaube
das war klug
ungestört richtete winter ihre
aufmerksamkeit auf das was der rose
vorstand ihre antwort war ausnahmslos
dieselbe die leute fragen immer war das
ihre lieblings kollektion war dass ihre
lieblingsaufgabe aber für mich ist es
immer die nächste das was kommt es ist
immer die zukunft die meisten redakteure
denken nicht über ihren täter hinaus
aber erinnert denkt über die welt nach
und wie sie den titel beeinflusst und
auch darüber wie der titel die welt
beeinflussen kann tanzen ist ist charles
townes früherer präsident des kontinents
sie kennt alle aspekte des marketing sei
es die vermarktung der marke für den
verbraucher oder für die werbepartner
es geht um politischen einfluss um
sozialen einfluss sie positioniert die
marke mit blick auf all diese parameter
um die marke zu erweitern brachte sie
2003 wittenburg heraus gefolgt von der
mensch vor und der vogue living
innerhalb eines jahres sanken jedoch die
werbeeinnahmen für die mensch burg um
über eine million dollar
2008 fünfte kontinent das magazin auf
eine gelegentliche beilage die vogue
living verschwand komplett
die markenerweiterung hatte am ende
nicht funktioniert sie war aber trotzdem
ein produktives experiment sie geht
risiken ein sie arbeitet wirklich sehr
hart wenn es nicht funktioniert dann
schiebt sie es beiseite erholt sich und
versucht einfach aus der sache zu lernen
und weiterzumachen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
winters erhöhte sichtbarkeit und ihre
öffentliche unterstützung der
pelzindustrie führten zu süden
konfrontation
auf dem höhepunkt der anti pelz bewegung
bei anna sehr bestimmt sie trug ihre
pelze oder stranden bei der chance auf
die art mittags im präsens und jemand
das tier auf den teller
zum ende durch paris los ist und jemand
dich mit pastete bewirkt und dich
niederschlägt ist das ziemlich aggressiv
aber sie stand auf wischte sich das
gesicht ab ging zurück ins hotel zog
sich um und ging zum nächsten treffen
danach bekamen sie personenschutz wenn
sie eine show besuchte hatte
das trug auch dazu bei dieser mythos zu
schüren das sie eine klasse für sich
sie steckte in ihrem stylish nicht die
lakers und ließ sich in ihrer
unterstützung für die milliardenschwere
pelzindustrie nicht irren die berühmte
sie wurde desto mehr negative
aufmerksamkeit bekam sie der roman der
teufel trägt prada wurde von vielen in
der modebranche als schlecht getarnte
und vernichtende darstellung von winter
angesehen
ein riesenerfolg und spielte weltweit
über 326 millionen dollar in den kinos
ein
[Musik]
dieser ruf des drachens wird oft
porträtiert ich glaube es gibt ja eine
art gender problem weil sie eine frau
ist erwarten die leute dass sie sich auf
eine bestimmte art und weise verhält
wenn sie eine firma leiten würde wäre
das überhaupt kein thema
winter war inzwischen eine anerkannte
größe mit weitreichenden
sie hat auch anderen sehr großen marken
geholfen
wenn die nach einem designer oder einem
kreativdirektor suchten hat sie auch
diesen marken zum erfolg verholfen
eine marke die ihre hilfe brauchte waage
seit jahren wird das unternehmen unter
sinkenden umsätzen die konsultierten
winter und sie empfahl den jungen
designer
sie hat mich angerufen und ich hatte
auch schon darüber nachgedacht und sie
erklärte mir wie dieser job aussehen
könnte also wie sie sich das vorstellen
würde
sie war ein großartiger resonanzboden
als ich über den job nachgedacht habe
anna winters anerkennung ist wichtig für
alles was ich mache ist es immer noch
sie sieht bis heute alles was ich tue
aber nach vier jahren glanzlose
ergebnisse endlich gab seinem star
designer winters interesse an der
förderung neuer talente ließ aber nicht
nach und sie gründete den burschen fand
die stipendien und unternehmen
für nachwuchs sorgen das war anna der
nicht
dass es mehr designer gibt also auch
mehr werbung und mehr umsatz das ist
alles ein kreis laufen
und so kamen 2007 börsen service mit der
septemberausgabe
das magazin hatte rekordverdächtige 7
127 seiten mit werbeanzeigen
die erfolgs dokumentation die
september-ausgabe der wert einen
seltenen einblick in die modewelt mit
der anspruchsvollen frau
es ist wunderschön danach bin ich nicht
so verrückt
wie sie schwanger aus nein dieser
schnitt wirkt so groß
sieht aus wie für eine blinde
[Musik]
männer schaut nicht zurück sie schaut
nach vorne sie verzweifelt nicht sie
vertraut sich selbst sie braucht eine
dicke haut aber auch unter einer dicken
haut sind nerven nerven aus stahl
brauchte sie
durch die rezession sagen wir uns mit
wirtschaftlichen umständen konfrontiert
die wir nie für möglich gehalten hätten
[Musik]
2009 zwang die tiefste rezession seit
jahrzehnten die unternehmen dazu
werbegelder
die anzeigen verkäufe davos für die
wichtige september-ausgabe brachen ein
von 727 auf 429
kontinents ist ein privates unternehmen
das keine finanzergebnisse
veröffentlicht aus
aber ganz offensichtlich stand das
unternehmen unter druck
und hunderte von stellen gestrichen
als aber auch in mode viertel von
manhattan der umsatz einbrachte
ihre idee war ein weltweites
verkaufsziel
das war ein beispielloses ereignis das
über 1000 einzelhändler auf der ganzen
welt zusammen brachte tausende und
abertausende von verbrauchern
überfluteten die geschäfte
das event war so erfolgreich dass es zu
einer jährlichen veranstaltung wurde wir
möchten uns bei euch allen für eure
kommen bedanken wie geht es euch heute
abend
winter sprang auch ein um einen der
schätze new yorks zu retten die kostüme
sammlung im metropolitan museum of art
als kopf einer spendenaktion moderierte
sie die jährliche benefiz gala
das war etwas das sogar mit den oscars
konkurrierte
damals präsidentin des metropolitan
museum of art in dem jahr haben wir
durch ihre führung in einer nacht über
neun millionen dollar gesammelt mitten
in einer rezession und es lagen noch
weitere gewaltige herausforderungen vor
winter konnten erst hatte sich nur
langsam an das digitale zeitalter
angepasst jetzt hängen winters zukunft
und die der vogue davon ab
jeder monatszeitschrift muss wirklich
prüfen ob bedarf an schnellen
informationen besteht und die decken
sind diese nachfrage
ihr monatlich erscheinendes magazin
sieht sich zunehmender konkurrenz durch
blogger und interaktive websites
ausgesetzt das gab designern eine neue
plattform um ihre entwürfe direkt zu
präsentieren und gleichzeitig ihre
produkte zu verkaufen ohne sich auf
hochglanzfotos strecken in der vogue zu
verlassen
winter teilte sich nun die begehrte
erste reihe mit den neuen medien
ich garantiere ihnen dass anna das spiel
der digitalen inhalte verändern wird
wir bringen markeninhalte mit ihrer
stimme zu millionen von verbrauchern die
wir mit einem magazin als einzige medium
unmöglich erreichen könnten
[Musik]
und dass kollegen wie auch ihre kritiker
glauben
[Musik]
einer macht fast jeden tag etwas das ist
enorm sie hat immer ideen wie man diese
branche voran bringen sie immer weiter
vorantreiben kann
diese industrie ist mehrere hundert
milliarden dollar schwer und das ist
vielleicht nur ein nebenprodukt von
vielen aber eines davon ist anders
leitung des mode magazins für mehr als
20 jahre
sie hat dieses unglaubliche gefühl dafür
was gute mode was talent und kreativität
sind die dvd ist
sie ist nicht hier nur um zu sagen ob
ein kleid schön ist oder nicht oder ob
ein neuer schuh groovig genug ist sie
ist da um die gesamte branche zu
ermutigen
nachwuchstalente etablierte talente für
alle ist es schwer im rennen zu bleiben
aber sie sieht das als ihre pflicht an
das ist auch ihr vermächtnis sie ist die
frau die mode wirklich in das big
business und in die welt gebracht hat
[Musik]
[Applaus]